dalla Gabriel thank you so much for
joining us and divided and wonderful
makes that where we always tend to do
for people who don't know who you are
how would you describe yourself so I
would probably describe myself first and
foremost as a writer
I'm also an academic and a researcher
and in terms of my politics I would
describe myself as a feminist and a
socialist as well and I think those two
things are really intimately tied well
what what does being a feminist then
that then mean to you and obviously
being a socialist you says it's very
firmly part about explain that so for me
feminism is sometimes misrepresented as
being about a battle of the sexes right
for me it's much more about a critique
of society as we run it I think that a
lot of the traits that we consider to be
feminine or that are labeled feminine
like care and intimacy and collectivism
and community should actually be
centered in our society rather than
sidelined and devalued and for me
feminism is very much about improving
the lives of women as a majority it's
looking at the most marginalized the
most vulnerable women and really
focusing on them rather than the kind of
hashtag I'm with her sort of Hillary
Clinton style feminist feminism of
putting basically just a woman on top of
a system that harms the majority of
women beneath it in terms of your own
feminism when did that start to come to
the fore because it's pretty clearly
anyone who's where of your work would
know it's pretty clearly a large part of
who you are it was through experiences
of harassment experience of assault that
I couldn't understand at the time and I
didn't understand a lot of the quite
contradictory in harm and and
overwhelming feelings that I had in as a
consequence of that and that turned me
on to first of all sort of feminist
literature so novelists like Noel Ansari
who's an Egyptian feminist that really
really influenced me and feminist
literature really helped me to make
sense of what happened and make sense of
why I was made to feel like I was to
blame so the kinds of
overwhelming changes are happening and
the events that were happening in my
life at the time and so first it became
a way to make sense of my own experience
and that's why it became so personal to
me and then once I've made that entry
point I then started to realize that
it's not that women's rights aren't
siphoned off from the rest of society it
was almost like a snowballing effect I
started with feminism and then I
realized women can't be free until you
know we defeat race oppression until we
fight class oppression because all of
these things are so intimately tied so
it was the entry point of politics for
me and has undergirded everything since
then my entry into politics was
emotional
before it was intellectual and that's
not something that I shy away from I
think that that is something I'm very
proud of but it's definitely something
that through explaining I've managed to
process the kind of various ways that
gender oppression race oppression
feature in my own life were you then as
influenced as much as much by the men
who were in your like men and boys who
were in your life during that time as
the feminist literature itself so I went
to an all-girls school you know for a
lot of my schooling and then in my last
two years of schooling I went to
actually an all-boys school that took in
a very small number of women in their
sick form so that was quite a formative
experience in me and seeing how a lot of
the masculine ways of forming social
bonds can be harmful to men it became
really clear to me that men didn't know
how to form relationships with women in
a way that was conducive for both their
happiness and healthiness
and women's happiness and healthiness
but I also think we do need to sometimes
shift away from dividing people into men
and women and look at people as being
sort of feminists or patriarchs because
you can have women who behave in a
patriarchal manner and pursue a
patriarchal system and men who are very
feminist in their orientation in terms
of where we are right now and of course
you one can't one can't generalize about
feminism as a whole but am I wrong to
detect that there are parts of
feminism these days that are that are
eyes angry about things that are going
on justifiably so in many many cases as
much as they have ever been perhaps
since the sixties the the level of anger
is it on occasion is comparable to back
then yes I think we saw a massive dip
right in the kind of naughties where
feminism really became a dirty words I
remember being the only only person
who's self-described as a feminist and
that all-boys school that I was talking
about and what happened how did that how
do people respond to that well it wasn't
easy and I think I faced a lot of
hostility not just from male students
but also from other female students it
was a difficult expect and I definitely
felt very alone now I think we're seeing
almost the opposites in that companies
and institutions are scrambling to be
seen as feminists and I think whilst
this has definitely created a space for
women to raise grievances and and for
kind of gendered oppression to be put
into the spotlight I think in some ways
it can be a poisoned chalice because it
can be very contradictory you look at
night for example who recently did a
campaign I think it was called look what
she's made of which was kind of about
again like appropriating that idea of
feminism or appropriating an aesthetic
of feminism but then you look at their
supply chains just last month 350 women
in their sweatshops were hospitalized
because of extreme fatigue from poor
working conditions so whilst I think
that it's definitely a plus that
feminism is not a dirty word anymore I
think what I don't want to see is a
defamed feminism that doesn't look at
the structural conditions that affect
women as a whole you know and
particularly marginalized and
working-class women as well I think
we're looking rather than looking to
rewire the system we're looking at sort
of getting women to play by the rules of
the game but the rules of the game are
rigged against the majority of women you
know at the moment you've got I stand
with her
you have the me2 movement in
International Women's Day is a feature
of any major organizations calendar now
taken together it doesn't that represent
significant or more than significant
progress I don't think we can look at it
as progress because when you look at the
in terms of I don't think it's a static
line sort of going up because if you
look at the first International Women's
Day that to me was one of the most
militant moments in feminist history you
had you know women garment workers
migrant women garment workers in New
York going on strike to demand better
conditions that was a collective demand
to change the collective experience of
women and to change the conditions of
the most vulnerable and the most
exploited women to me that's more
progress than a kind of feminism that
focuses on putting a female head at the
top of a system that entrenches
inequality seventy percent of the
world's poor are women so if you
perpetuate a system that increases that
inequality women are going to be at the
sharp edge of that I mean a woman you
could perhaps have have included in that
description I mean Hillary Clinton so
much of her campaign to become president
was about having a woman as as the first
president I mean didn't she have a point
I mean wouldn't that have been more than
us like again more than a significant
step forward for there to be the first
female president of the United States
so representation is obviously important
it's obviously important to see people
that look like you being celebrated and
being revered right or being trusted
with that kind of decision-making power
but I don't think the representation is
a replacement for systemic change when
you look at Hillary Clinton specifically
and you look at for example the fact
that she was completely embedded with
the fossil fuel industry you know the
fossil fuel industry contributed
millions of dollars to her campaign when
you look at the impacts of climate
change in the impact of the fossil fuel
industries extractivism globally eighty
percent of the people that are displaced
by climate change are women we know that
women are the most affected by climate
change so to me that's a massive
contradiction and I don't think that
it's a fair payoff a lot of what you're
saying seems to go to something that
you've talked about in your writing the
idea that feminine I don't know P words
in your mouth but the idea that feminism
might be incompatible with capitalism a
system that has inequality at its heart
I fundamentally don't think can be
compatible
with an ideology with a politics that
fights for liberation for all I don't
think it's an accident that 70% of the
world's poor are women so for me
socialism and feminism or rewiring our
economic system to be more equal and
more based in care and more based in
justice is intimately tied with gender
equality and ending gender oppression in
terms of where feminism sits at the
moment at times it does whether there
are voices within the feminist movement
that seem to have an issue with with
with trans with trans politics as well
do you understand where where some of
these people are coming from and are on
that issue there's something being lost
from the notion of what it is to be a
woman I absolutely don't think that
we're seeing the most privileged sector
of women trying to just trying to police
the boundaries of womanhood in order to
maintain some kind of power within this
movement trans politics is inherently
feminist politics because it challenges
the primp the gender binary and that's
fundamentally what feminism has always
done so what what then is the rule of
men in this in this struggle I mean can
a man be a feminist can someone without
the experiences that you have had be a
feminist truly I completely believe they
can of course because patriarchy is a
system that yes it benefits men more
than it benefits women but it still does
hurt men because it's a system that is
based on competition on violence on
oppression on hierarchy and that is
something that effects men as well as
women but women do obviously suffer the
brunt of it can you understand why there
are some men who feel perhaps rightly
perhaps wrongly that for women to rise
someone else has to be brought down well
I think that that's symptomatic of the
way that our economic and political
system is set up it's set up on the
premise of hierarchy on the premise that
it's okay I think it's the top 27
richest people in the world owning more
wealth than the bottom 50% so when you
have a system that's been
based on hierarchy and based on the
incredible riches of some and the
incredible poverty of the many then of
course you would think oh if for some
people to be liberated other people need
to be put down but when you rewire the
entire way that you envisage society you
can see that actually our liberation is
completely tied together and that's why
for me the Hillary Clinton style
feminism the Teresa may style feminism
that focuses on the progression of
individual very privileged women is not
interesting to me because it doesn't
capture that radical potential that
feminism has to change society for
everyone I have no interest in leaning
into a system that has inequality at its
heart and I have no interest in smashing
a glass ceiling if it means that the
majority of the web of poor women are
cleaning up the shards of that glass
ceiling